if we had a functioning news media which
we don't there's a video that would be
leading every newscast right now it has
nothing to do with a plane crash in
Russia a GOP Primary debate or even the
indictment of every lawyer who's ever
given Donald Trump legal advice as
important as all those topics may be
but this video is about Americans
including children who died horribly
this month it's about how their deaths
could have been prevented if their
government was even remotely competent
the footage I'm talking about is an
interview with a survivor of the fires
in Maui this interview was uh conducted
not by CNN or NPR but by a real estate
agent Who moonlights as a citizen
journalist
and he spoke with a man who goes by the
name fish who survived the blaze in
Lahaina uh and and here's what that man
saw listen
and I went out and I saw the fire and he
couldn't even see the Gateway because it
was covered with smoke and everyone's
standing around just looking and I said
I think we should get out of here
because of the speed of this wind it
could be here in two minutes so I went
around back to Front Street and there
was all the cars were lined up but none
of them were moving and I walked all the
way from Safeway to the Chart House not
one car is moved and I was wondering
what was stopping the traffic well it
was a policeman and I got to the end and
I looked up north there were no
obstructions there was no reason to keep
those cars are you serious I'm serious
as a heart attack and I I said what are
you doing he goes well I'm under orders
to keep them here and I said the fire is
is right around Safeway it's going to
hit Front Street you know these people
got to get out of here and he said I'm
following order no way and I saw I just
kept walking them maybe you know
something I don't you know so and I keep
walking down the highway and I look
behind no cars are coming out I walked
all the way to waikuli beach still no
cars coming out and I started hearing
boom boom boom then I heard people
screaming and stuff you're saying they
were blockaded in by the police at the
end of Front Street yeah like where the
restaurant is where the Chart House
where the Chart House was I should say
there was a blockade there and they
could not go anywhere from Safeway to
there not one car had moved I mean it's
it's amazing and we get that video from
whether it goes Hawaii
realestate.org gives us that video with
that information
he says all the cars were lined up but
none of them were moving and I was
wondering what was stopping the traffic
it was a policeman
a policeman
sitting there trapping all of these
people in in the what is soon to be an
Inferno
and as incredible as that account may
seem it's clear now that it's accurate
there are multiple Witnesses saying the
same thing the Associated Press reports
that uh as residents of one West Mound
neighborhood tried to flee using the
only paved Road in town quote car after
car was turned back toward the rapidly
spreading Wildfire by a barricade
blocking access to Highway 30. turn back
towards the fire
supposedly authorities were worried
about downed power lines and there
certainly were we can assume plenty of
downed power lines but the problem is
that the other option rather than
navigating around that Hazard was to
stay and die in The Blaze
seems obvious which was the better
choice and yet police tried to force the
residents to stay put
many who listened and turned back you
know ended up burning to death in their
cars
being literally cooked to death in their
cars the most horrific death imaginable
others were forced to jump over the sea
wall and tread water while inhaling
smoke
the people who obeyed the authorities
ended up dead in many cases
it's as simple as that
on the other hand people who ignored the
authorities fared a lot better around 3
P.M for example a man named Nate Baird
and his family tried to Drive South out
of town but found that the road was
blocked by cones and Crews who were
quote working on downed electric poles
according to the AP that's when bear
decided to ignore what the work Crews
told him he drove around the cones and
his family traveled for about an hour
until they reached safety the article
lists several other examples of people
who are alive today because they ignored
barricades they ignored the extra
instructions from authorities and they
did what they knew was the smartest
thing
138 year old woman Kim Cuevas Reyes
ignored authorities instructions to turn
towards the local Civic Center which
became an ad hoc shelter for refugees
instead of doing that the AP reported
quote she takes a left driving in the
wrong lane to pass a stack of cars
heading in the other direction
that decision saved her life quote the
gridlock would have left us there when
the Firestorm started the woman said uh
quote I would have had to tell my
children to jump into the ocean as well
and be boiled alive by the flames
or it would have just died from smoking
inhalation and roasted in the car
it wasn't until several hours later that
authorities announced that the road out
of Lahaina was open for traffic several
hours later by that point indeed many
people on that road called Front Street
had burned to death in their car so or
died of smoking inhalation
now how is it possible that authorities
blocked off
one of the only usable routes
that would have brought them to safety
during a wildfire
given that officials in Hawaii were
aware of the risk of wildfire for a long
time that is an excellent question
now last summer in regulatory filings
Hawaii electric made it clear that the
risk of deadly wildfires was real
especially during high winds
and yet apparently the plan for dealing
with this kind of disaster didn't
preclude sealing all the roads and
trapping people in the middle of a
wildfire
now if you think back to Hurricane
Katrina as we made this comparison a few
days ago
one of the biggest failures of FEMA back
then was a lack of planning the
government ran evacuation simulations
but didn't implement the necessary
improvements after those simulations so
when the hurricane struck there was
chaos a lot of people died as a result
and we're seeing that exact same thing
yet again
all these years later the same lack of
preparation preparation for uh for for
hazards and catastrophes that are
foreseeable
that's what's causing people to die
the difference is that we aren't hearing
much about FEMA in the aftermath of the
catastrophe in Maui and why is that it's
a good question
Deanne Criswell is the administrator of
FEMA she's the um that's the Federal
Emergency Management agency she had the
same job that Michael Brown did in 2005
when Hurricane Katrina made landfall in
New Orleans and brown you might remember
became a household name in the wake of
that disaster and not in a good way
when George Bush told Brown that he was
doing a heck of a job it instantly
became a national scandal
Brown was so radioactive that no one was
allowed to say anything nice about him
unlike Michael Brown though Deanne
Creswell is not well known
you've probably never even heard her
name I didn't know it until I looked it
up
despite the ongoing disaster in Maui the
national news media and the major
political parties in Washington
still hold her somehow in high regard
just the other day she sat for a
friendly interview on Face the Nation
this is after the disaster and the
bungled handling of that disaster but
listen to how this interview went watch
FEMA director Deanne Criswell toured the
damage yesterday with local officials
our Jonathan Vigliotti spoke with her
after
you were on the ground touring the
disaster Zone what did you see and what
struck you the most
breaking to just see an entire community
that is no longer there and I think one
of the things that was just really the
most shocking I guess I would say is the
row of cars of people that were trying
to drive and escape and then couldn't
get out fast enough and these are the
ones that ended up running or jumping
into the water and those cars just there
I mean it was like a scene from an
apocalyptic movie so they burned out
cars with the most shocking thing says
the FEMA director it was like an
apocalyptic movie
there's no scrutiny from Face the Nation
or any media Outlet about why those cars
were stranded there in the first place
there wasn't any question in that
segment about why FEMA didn't have
evacuation plans that might have ensured
the survival of all those people as
central banks and countries like China
India and Australia begin transitioning
to a digital currency the Federal
Reserve has been contemplating the same
for the U.S with the digital currency
the government could track every single
purchase you make officials could even
prohibit you from purchasing certain
products or easily freeze or seize part
or all of your money these are some of
the reasons concerned Americans reach
out to Birch gold they want to have a
physical asset like gold that's
independent of the US dollar and you
could protect your IRA or 401K by
diversifying with gold from virtual
historically gold has been a safe haven
in times of high uncertainty which is
right now learn if gold is right for you
too text Walsh to 989-898 and they'll
send you a free info kit on gold with an
A plus rating with the Better Business
Bureau thousands of happy customers and
countless five star reviews I trust
Birch gold to help you diversify into
gold if a central bank digital currency
becomes a reality it'll be nice to have
some gold to depend on again text Walsh
to 98 9898
we learned yesterday that Hawaii's top
emergency response officials were on
another Island supposedly learning how
to respond to wildfires on the day the
blaze began in Maui and some key Federal
disaster officials were apparently busy
at some FEMA meetings
well what explains that again we have no
idea because no one is asking
reporters are busy talking to Deanne
Criswell the FEMA director like she's
some bystander visiting Maui for the
first time this is the opposite of how
the Press treated Michael Brown decades
ago
it's not hard to see why this might be
the case Dan Criswell unlike Michael
Brown is working for Democrats she's
also the first woman to run FEMA so she
has the whole identity politics thing
going it would look very bad if the
first woman to run FEMA is also
responsible for bungling the response to
one of the worst disasters in American
history
of course no matter how it looks that's
exactly what happened
but the media has decided to plug its
ears and close its eyes and pretend it's
not happening
but if you do what what no major media
Outlet is interested in doing if you
look into criswell's past there's a lot
to discuss
as investigative journalist Nick sortor
pointed out the other day criswell's
government biography states that quote
one of her most significant
accomplishments was leading the
coordination of New York City's response
to the covid-19 pandemic when she served
as the commissioner of the New York City
Emergency Management Department
now New York's handling of coven you
might remember it led to more than ten
thousand deaths in nursing homes
deaths that were under counted for
several months until investigative
reporters noticed discrepancies in the
government data government stated this
is also these are also deaths that were
totally avoidable
but they made the decision in New York
City to take people that they knew were
infected with coven and put them in
nursing homes right in the middle of
these uh places where where you have the
most vulnerable populations
and 10 000 people at least died as a
result
now in most countries everyone
overseeing a response like that would
never work again in any capacity much
less in disaster relief
they go to prison for life if anything
but Dan Criswell was never even
criticized
in fact she got a promotion
ten thousand deaths in nursing homes and
she got promoted
and then overseeing yet another failed
Disaster Response she gets softball
questions from every news Outlet
which is astonishing really
we've seen our Public Health authorities
and political leaders lead us into one
disaster after another and they're not
slowing down
right now because it's an election year
and Pfizer stock is in trouble the media
is as it happens is gearing up for covid
2.0
several major corporations and some
universities are already implementing
Mass mandates again they're gearing up
to do the whole thing over again watch
you're sick of hearing about covet so
are we the problem is what is coming
because of this new wave of covid that
is really statistically meaningless
what's coming is really important
because as George predicted
some people just can't let go of the
emergency more importantly the emergency
Powers Lions Gate entertainment out in
Hollywood is back to masks and testing
we talked about colleges yesterday there
are now 104 colleges in the U.S still
mandating coveted vaccines for students
of course faculty are Exempted some have
indicated they will never let this go
all the while they refuse to make sense
of their pseudoscience on the list
Rutgers Harvard and more we can now add
that Morris Brown College in Atlanta
and the Seattle government who are never
wrong the government doctors didn't get
a thing wrong during coven they want
mandatory face masks for health care
workers now along these lines CNN just
published an article entitled it may be
time to break out the masks against
kovid some experts say
they're the experts again
the report scolds Americans for not
being sufficiently deferential to people
with Advanced degrees and positions of
power quote despite the concern among
experts in some institutions Americans
don't appear to be worried enough about
the don't appear to be worried enough
they say about the recent rise in cases
to change their behavior covid-19 was at
the bottom of the list of key Public
Health threats according to the latest
axios poll
that's not hard to see why Americans are
reacting that way the first time around
more than three years ago the
conventional wisdom was that if you
wanted to survive your best bet was to
trust the experts and the experts
embarrassed themselves and were revealed
to be lying one after another you know
they said that you could protest for BLM
and be safe but you couldn't protest
against lockdowns they admitted they
were lying about herd immunity
they misled everyone on the
effectiveness of the covid shot on masks
on everything
nobody really trusts these experts
anymore for good reason
that's encouraging but the truth is it's
not enough
a lot of people just died in Maui
because officials forcibly blockaded
them
the government and the experts prevented
these American citizens from leaving
their neighborhood as a wildfire
approached them they burned to death
because they were trapped there
by the authorities
the only way to survive was not simply
to doubt
not simply be to be skeptical but to
actively disobey what you're being told
by the authorities
now when the next lockdown comes whether
the pretext is a coveted variant a
climate emergency or something else
that's going to be the correct response
do what Nate Baird did
in Maui
ignore the Liars calling themselves
experts
do what you think is best for yourself
and your family and and do it fast
otherwise quicker than you might think
you'll be trapped
and by that point like the people of
Maui
there will be no way out
because the fact is that increasingly
we live in a country where only those
who disobey disobey
Will Survive
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there